how can one tell that a filmmaker is
before their time in the current day and
not 20 years from now realizing huh and
they were a pioneer oh I guess there
before their time if people simply don't
respond if they simply don't emotionally
get what the heck is going on in this
film um I have a difficult question
though how can we tell whether there
before their time tell me some more yeah
is it maybe I'm apologies if I'm not
explaining it correctly I guess there's
been so many people that were shunned
during their time from their peers
whether it's van Gogh or certain people
that once they passed away and years it
you know had gone by then people
realized how you know much of a sort of
a genius they were and I'm just
wondering if there are any sort of
telltale signs but maybe that's it then
just people that don't sort of fit the
mold they don't fit in there not really
regarded you know there's that that
biblical saying sort of no man's a
prophet in his own land type of thing
and maybe that's it so maybe someone
that's heralded as sort of a hero now
maybe wouldn't be into it's all you know
it's very hard to say I i would say that
filmmaker from the past like this Paul
lejos made one movie a lonesome
beautiful beautiful fabulous film it
never connected it languished for years
it's been recently rediscovered and
people can now see it for the wonderful
mythic film it was but it didn't connect
it maybe it wasn't marketed right maybe
he simply did not know to bring it to
but it's I think at the moment it's kind
of hard to tell time tells all and
that's one of those values of history
that you can look back and see things
that seem valuable art
things that seemed unvalued well our
that's the one of the benefits of
thinking historically
you